now let's
let's get to japan airlines flight
1628 in 1986. right
that was that's another instance where i
knew about that incident in 1986 i
remember watching it on
nbc news with tom brokaw and i remember
um him discussing this and then playing
some of the
um some of the audio from the pilot
and the air air traffic control
and i remembered thinking that this is
really pretty amazing you've got
a you've got a um
you've got a large um jet
it was a 747 i guess it was um
and it's basically flying from they were
flying from
paris to tokyo bringing bourgeois
nouveau
so here now we can all have a giggle
hahaha he's got a plane full of
uh wine right um but
it is so supposed to be the aliens were
after all
that's right and you were an undergrad
at this point i was an undergrad at the
point
studying math and physics math yeah okay
great great great
yeah so so the um and you can actually
still find
the um news reports online the videos
people put them online
but the um
so as they're flying they're approaching
anchorage alaska
and um they see some lights in the
distance basically approaching the plane
and so they're concerned so they call um
air traffic to control to see if they
have any traffic for them
and air traffic control says negative um
they said
well we see traffic there we've got
um several craft approaching and so
they're
very concerned about this so approaching
anchorage they have
um two craft approaching and then
um and then shortly thereafter a larger
craft
approaches and the thing is walnut
shaped and glowing
and at one point it's it's in front of
the aircraft
and the pilot described it as so big
that they couldn't see out of the
windscreen
so i mean you're you're a pilot of a jet
you've got something in front of you
that you can't see beyond
that's a scary prospect um
so he's panicked and calling air traffic
control and they don't
they're not picking anything up on radar
except his plane
and at some point the military is
contacted and gets involved
and on military height finding radar
they pick up
um the larger craft on the plane and the
airplane so they pick up both objects
so the so the military is able to detect
this with their radar
um were you able to estimate the size of
the craft
um no uh he estimated it to be
um the size of i think it was three
747s so it's basically the size of an
aircraft carrier
so you've got this guy you've got a
flying aircraft carrier shaped like a
walnut
um now you then you have to ask
how wrong can the pilot be i mean it's
all right maybe it wasn't as big as an
aircraft carrier maybe it was just the
size of a destroyer
still that's pretty amazing right he
said it was glowing
i mean glowing yeah and this was at
night um
i i don't know what time it happened i
don't recall
that's all that's all recorded but i
don't recall off the top of my shirt
is that it with the japan airlines
flight is there more no well the thing
the the interesting thing is the object
follows him for 40 minutes
so it isn't just like i saw it it was
gone no this thing basically kept track
kept along with the airplane for 40
minutes and it basically moved around
the aircraft
and moved around the airplane as time
went by so
it would go so the military height
finding radar in this radar data
exists you can look at this the military
finding radar is sweeping every 10
seconds
and the um craft is about seven and a
half miles away from the airplane
and in one sweep it'll be at one o'clock
in the next sweep 10 seconds later the
thing could be at six o'clock
and so the thing is literally jumping
around this airplane and the
pilots panicked he actually takes some
evasive maneuvers at some point
to try to evade the object and thought
that he had he didn't see it
and the um air force comes on and goes
now it's behind you
it's still following you it's behind you
so um the thing basically followed him
for 40 minutes
you